Dancing if she says there's no audio in-game.
What goes up must come down.
Let me do a live chat.
Hold on, let me do a live chat.
Wait, there we go.
It felt tough, but it wouldn't work.
Good morning!
Good morning.
Good evening, good afternoon.
I'm Strony Cuttles.
I'm supposed to be the hypnotist.
And I've produced nothing hypnotist-wise, except that one live stream.
I've only slept two fucking hours.
What a good song.
That's a good song and that's a good show.
That's not gonna stop me, okay?
That's not gonna stop me.
I'd like to apologise to any bleeding hearts who may be lurking.
Oh my, what's this sayfile?
Hmm, looks oddly familiar.
If I click start, is it gonna remember that I did...
Did I do Sonic?
Does it remember?
Oh wow, it did.
I only slept two hours, cracks the can of cola for the fucking any ounce of the thingy.
I can't believe this, remember?
Holy crap.
So we've actually done Team Rose and Team Sonic.
Never done Team Chaotic.
I've never done Dark, but we may actually have 100% sayfile, which I didn't expect.
So we are playing Team Chaotic.
Now I know it's really weird setup.
There's like a big black gap in between me, but it's fine.
We're just painting, don't you mind, painting.
But we're jumping straight into...
It's here, it's here.
We've got work.
I've heard good things about you.
I would like to order your detective services.
Yeah, detective services.
34 aspect ratio.
I actually have a layout that's 34.
Don't be silly.
We never turned down work that pays.
So I've never actually completed these guys past the power point, power station map.
Could you just show the whole abstract?
You want me to be full body?
I missed the first minute of stront is over.
Oh no, I started early.
See.
So this is Team Chaotic.
I'll talk a little bit in the background.
Hold on, how about I do my yapping?
I actually went back in the binding of Isaacs dream because it was so good.
I team stamped it myself so people can enjoy me.
Freaking playing the loss.
I can't believe I did that and I don't know for any of you who didn't watch the binding of Isaacs.
I don't know why I'm frog blinking.
I promise I'm not frog blinking in real life, okay?
Frickin, I pulled the holy mantle card at the last possible second before delirium got me, okay?
Before delirium zapped my butt cheeks.
Um, you can literally hear me pull the card and then the crack on delirium.
I didn't, I didn't realize I did it because it went so, it went by so quick.
Three whole timestamps there.
Um, but yeah, I, oh my god, fantastic.
I cannot believe that Binding of Isaac Run happened.
I don't know what streamer luck I'm getting and Beltrow and Isaac and all of it.
Such a gamer honestly, an accidental gamer.
Me like, should I break up Brimstone?
Just waiting for you guys to tell me what to do.
I was barely able to sleep after the excitement.
I genuinely couldn't even process, like I looked back on it and I'm like,
Stranny, Stranny for fuck's sake, you just, you just did delirium by accident.
Like when I was lucky enough to even get access to the delirium portal.
Um, I have my first Patreon audio upload this month.
The next one is going to be coming out in two or three days.
Bleeding Hearts, Azura's first one is going to come out after asleep.
I'm so sorry for the delay.
There's a lot of shit happening behind the scenes, but there's a fantastic, um,
news that's going to be broken soon-ish.
I can't break it yet, but once it gets broken,
you'll understand like, oh, some stuff had to happen in the background.
Oh, and, um, so yes, I am very excited about that.
Sorry for the delay.
Get it, delay, because it's French and you say, doodly.
Yeah, that's right.
I named them after French stuff.
No, I'm not naming any other gen after them.
So I'm sorry, but Fond de la Buzum will never be recreated and you'll never get it back.
Um, huge news puns.
But then again, yes, the stream went all according to the script.
Well done, everybody.
Stop it!
People are going to think this is pre-recorded reflames.
Um, I have a, I accidentally slipped into another ASMR collab with someone.
I'm terrible.
I've, I was going to announce,
I've finally caught up with all scripts with all my ASMR collab, collab partners.
And I, I fricking slipped and stumbled into another one.
I don't know how I keep happening.
Um, but, uh, I've got, I actually have collabs in August.
I think with people outside of violour.
Oh no, I have to be, I have to be social.
I have to, I have to understand what people want and be nice and stuff.
Yeah.
Oh, we started early.
Yes, I apologize.
For any snowberries that might be lost,
I just realized there was no background in game audio.
Um, YouTube, please stop prompting me to insert ads.
I'd appreciate it.
Speaking of YouTube and ads,
uh, all my streams are getting limited all of a sudden.
And I'm like, I don't think I'm saying anything that outrageous.
And I might be overly swearing because I do swear a lot.
Mm, I do mean, um,
mommy's normal now, honestly.
Be gentle with yourselves.
You've been top tier streaming for a while,
luncheon and top tier company, company.
I'm personally helpful in lots.
You deserve all the praise and slack.
Oh, give me that slack.
Give me your slack refund.
Oh, also me.
I wonder why I keep getting limited ads.
Hmm.
Curious.
Uh, curious, curious.
Is there some sort of correlation?
Hmm.
Who knows?
The Ys.
Good morning.
Good evening.
Good afternoon.
I'm Stewanyi.
My voice is broken because I've overused it too much.
My dad actually made a comment.
He was like, your voice does not sound like your voice.
But on stream, it sounds actually relatively fine.
The microphone is covering how damaged my voice is.
Um, I, yes, a Patreon audio came out.
It's helped me.
I mentioned this a little bit the other day
on how good my accent is for ignore popcorn.
Um, I have, I have a very good voice for ignore slash free use.
And I've only just realized it.
And I'm like, maybe I should dip into it a bit more.
Because like, I have a really, uh, just do what you want.
Let me just keep playing Sonic Heroes.
Come on.
I literally, it's terrible.
But I'm like, oh no, I have a really good voice for it.
Like, that's the thing I would have had to pick.
Because I've been struggling with my accent.
I feel quite, I feel quite self-conscious with my accent
when I'm recording that kind of stuff.
Because it sounds rather odd.
I'm like, oh, a refline, were you then?
Oh, do you like how that feels?
Like, I'm struggling a wee bit.
But, you know, nothing we can't overcome together.
So I'm not going to try and get into my head too much.
Because at the end of the day,
we're making Shakespeare out here.
We're making things to Shakespeare out here.
Me and the boys.
Um, quite unique, yes.
Um, so I actually thought my dad was here longer.
Um, than our original, I thought it was three weeks.
Unless the days have gone by so quick.
But he's actually getting shipped out in two weeks.
Technical is dead if Johnny doesn't join the audio though.
Your voice and accent are very cute.
I love it. Oh, thank you very much.
That's very kind.
The music is a bit loud, by the way.
What music?
You shouldn't hear anything right now.
Everything should be muted.
It should be my voice and nothing more.
Do you mean Sonic Heroes at the start when I was singing?
I meant, I'm inclined to believe you.
I am.
It's true.
I hear no music shipped out, bro.
Yeah, he's getting shipped.
As a Scot, I'm happy to have more Scot audios.
That one bit him.
That one was bit him, Swerdy.
Thank you.
Wait, why is that?
That is echoing.
Hold on.
What was the joke?
Take what joke I said.
Hold on.
What was the joke?
Go back.
It was schizophrenia.
I had another tab open.
It started playing music.
Oh dear.
The refunds are losing it.
Wait, what was the joke?
I forgot what I said.
The Shakespeare one.
You know, we're not out here to make Shakespeare.
We're just making stuff to shake your spirit.
Oh, and it didn't play.
Okay.
It didn't play.
Wait, why no?
Why did you get?
I got stage fright.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got stage fright.
Are you okay, little guy?
Little stream deck.
Are you all right there?
He got shy.
Oh, poor guy.
Oh, great.
I'm like, come on.
Where's my cue?
Okay.
I'm going to slurp my tea,
and then we'll get into shanic heroes.
I've already lost the speed run.
We're already 1 second, 0.98 miller or something.
I'm a sleepy boy, sleepy baby,
but I'm going to have fun.
We're going to play Team Chaotic.
I have never successfully as a child
played Team Chaotic.
The only team I played successfully
was Rose, Team Rose,
which is the easiest team.
Now Chaotic's a bit different.
They have the same map pool, etc.
However, they do little side funny missions
where you don't necessarily have to
reach the end of the lobby.
So we'll have a little...
I never ended up playing most of the Sonic games.
Neither did I.
Please don't worry.
This is literally the only...
I played this.
I played Sonic Unleashed,
but I got stuck as a child in Sonic Unleashed.
I don't know how young I was,
but I was too young to comprehend
what I was supposed to do,
and I got stuck in the first 10 minutes
of Sonic Unleashed.
That's how young I was when I played it.
I don't even know what year it came out,
but I couldn't even figure out the freaking thing.
You never finish this game as a child.
Apparently it's a secret ending if we're 100% it,
so we might return,
because I do have a save file.
I love Sonic Unleashed.
I beat it like 2 years ago.
Ah, Unleashed, Kino.
Wait, so you never saw the final level,
and it has the best OST ever?
In Sonic Heroes?
No, I've not.
The only one I played was the worst one
with all the loading screens.
I don't know what that...
I played Sonic 06.
Small, strong, all we need.
Little, baby, small and so.
Yeah, you have to beat it all the teams.
Oh, okay.
Maybe we'll have a little visit back.
I can't vouch for it.
Yeah, right now, but...
Hold on, let me slurp my tea again.
You got all the emeralds?
I purposely skip the keys.
I don't even pick them up.
I skip them,
because I don't want to do those bonus levels
with the freaking balloons.
They annoy me so much.
Oh, I think it was 2006.
Big nostalgia time.
Yes, Imi from Yumi Plus
is also going on an absolute Sonic boonage.
So if you're a Sonic fan,
I kid you not,
type in ImiYumiPlus.
You're welcome.
That's all I'm saying.
Literally, out of the floodgates,
and she's obsessed with Shadow,
the hedgehog, bless her.
She fucking goes,
Coconuts for Shadow.
Hi, woman.
Hello, we playing.
Sorry for starting early.
I might have jump-scared somebody out.
Whoa, you're too early.
Look.
If I remember correctly,
when you get here,
you aren't allowed to get one hit,
or you perish.
She's totally not down bad
with Shadow for real, for real.
Imi was so nice to me in the end.
So if you didn't know,
Imi is Ozzy.
And I was like,
please for the love of God,
tell me you're in my city.
I will literally do an off collab with you.
You'll be the first person I off collab with.
And she names the wrong bloody city.
I'm like, bruv, it was a 50 fucking 50.
And she's in the wrong one.
She's in the wrong one.
It was a 50 50.
So I'm on the hunt
for a freaking
Melbourne
bloody
a streamer VTuber
that's comfortable with me.
Well, uncomfortable, you know,
lead tubers in general.
Who is Imi?
Imi is from Yumi Plus.
I collabed with her on Among Us,
and I framed her twice in a row.
I'm sorry about that.
I do apologize.
You were very easy to pick on
in my defense.
Hello, Momay reflinks.
Good morning.
Did you miss the chow garden?
I never played that mini game.
You know, never lucky.
So I'm sure there's a Melbourneian VTuber
that's crazy enough
to let me come over to their house.
I'll get it.
I'll get there.
Don't you worry.
Imi is the plague doctor one with red and white.
And I basically gaslit everyone
into thinking it was her.
And she got so she got so taken aback
because no one's heard me.
No, no one's actually heard me
be aggressive or blamey.
Like I've always come.
I'm always chill.
I'm always being chining.
That's all.
So I think everyone was like stunned
that I came out of the gates on Among Us
like it's her.
Here's the here.
It was the candlestick
in the the ball yard room.
Get her.
Okay.
And then we did because I got
a wave that twice in the same lobby
and then she be caught on
to what the deal was going.
So I had to start reversing it and stuff.
Angry Strony was scary but hot.
Well, I don't think anyone expected it.
And I think I took everyone off guard.
So everyone believed me
for like the first two rounds
and then everyone started to get
real sussy of me.
Mmm.
The Scottish Cutfish Reacher for Bean Camp.
Well, sometimes, okay.
But yeah, I think I took everyone off guard
by Among Us.
But I'm currently working on a four-man
collab with people outside of Vealur.
And I'm like, I have to be social.
I'm so scared.
But at the same time, literally no one
has rejected me so far.
So I'm like, hi, I'm Strony.
Do you want a collab?
Here's the time and date.
Show up.
I'll show up in an hour early.
Smile.
Like, people, the way Veach over Twitter
portray everyone being so shy
and scared to talk to each other,
it's actually stopping people
from just straight-up collabing.
You know, you don't have to know
absolutely everything about each other to collab.
I tell a crazy concept.
I know absolutely earth-shattering news.
But every time I've collabed with someone,
they're like, yeah, no one asks me anything.
And I'm like, oh, okay, well,
I'm glad I could break the curse,
because literally you just DM and be like,
hi, I'm Strony from Vealur when I hang out.
Smile.
Need more Vealur Umi Plus collabs?
Well, hold on to your hat, because August.
Unfortunately, I can't really do any collabs this month
because of Matt Dad situation.
But once he goes home,
I am then in a deficit of membership streams.
Please don't think I'm neglecting membership streams.
There's probably going to be like daily ones.
Strony, you have just tremendously metaphorical ballbags.
That's all.
Oh, who goes there?
That's exactly how I get all of the juice.
Almost threw up there.
If that was lovely first thing in the morning,
let's not do that.
Tisker.
I also have a community post.
If you have any words you want me to say in an ASMR,
that's going to get recorded like first thing
when my dad gets shipped,
because when I get sad,
I'll just throw myself into work.
So don't be surprised when you see a bunch of ASMR
come out right at the end of the month.
A burpee ASMR.
I've already made a burpee ASMR.
It's on Patreon right now,
but I can't put on YouTube yet,
because I have a warning,
and I don't know if YouTube is going to give me a strike for it.
So I need to wait until the old strike is gone.
Anonymous.
Nine tenths.
Why did you give me $30 for a burpee?
Thank you. $30 Anonymous?
Nine out of 10.
How is that not...
Did it need more base for you, sir?
Sir, do you require more base with your burps?
Sure, anything for you.
All right.
Okay.
I'll finish my teeth.
There are dollars based.
Lol, restart my phone.
I immediately agreed to a 10 out of 10 bell
that you're going to wake up your dad for that one.
Lol.
A burp that transcends the mortal coil.
Mm. Okay.
Oh, I just remembered I was going to write a script for Sheebie,
and I didn't.
Shit.
Is she ongoing?
Oh, I just remembered I was supposed to do that right now.
Okay, it's fine.
I have time.
I will teach the girls how to make scripts at a later date.
For now, I will do it on their behalf.
I will teach them their way.
Okay.
This is going to get loud.
Jumpscare warning for the game sound.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can't control the camera.
Let's go.
Script writing stream instead.
No, I can't seem to do it live anymore.
I don't know what's going on.
Look, it's a little hermit crab.
And we're to collect 10 hermit crabs.
Um, no louder please.
Oh, I'm a bumblebee, so I pollinate the flower.
Sorry.
I saw.
Oh, right.
Okay.
It's first thing in the morning.
Be nice to me.
You get the last one.
No.
I need a level up because so in Sonic Heroes,
you have your strength type, you have your flying type,
and you have your sneak for speed.
I am a bias towards the flying one because this game,
you can seriously like, oh my god, look at the hair of it as eyes.
That's terrible.
I love it more.
The pollination mentioned on a little.
What's that do a bubble?
Right.
We're not going for the key.
I've had enough key.
Why does Gator sound like Uncle Ruckus?
Who's Uncle Ruckus?
Am I being dumb?
Wow.
So we are literally our mission isn't to like kill all the robots,
get to the end.
It's to collect these little adorable hermit crabs.
Hey, so let's get to it.
Is the cook?
Oh god, I've forgotten what button the ultimate is.
It says press Z, but there's no Z.
I must be a bumper.
Surely it's a bumper.
There's a little army club.
Hello.
I have no idea.
Oh no, I can't be.
All right.
Okay.
Oh god, I love this game so much.
If you didn't know.
Wait, was there?
No, there wasn't a hermit crab on that one.
That's fine.
Um, probably right bumper.
Oh, not vector.
Oh wait, those are level ups.
Okay.
That's good.
Um, but yes, I apologize if this is just absolutely trash string
because I can't string a sentence together.
The truth is I didn't sleep.
I, so my dad took me to Bunnens.
So I've got a, I'm going to change the cats.
Oh, there's a wee hermit crab.
I need to change the cat litter box after this strum.
Oh god, I go up.
What happens if I go up?
Is that up here?
There is there a hermit crab up here?
Be honest.
No, go and get the rest.
Hey, so yeah, if I'm quiet, please don't think it's big.
Are you okay game?
Okay.
Please don't think it's because I'm like being a stinky streamer
and don't want to talk.
It's because I don't have, I didn't know you had a flamethrower.
It's because I'm dumb and I didn't sleep,
but I'm going to get loads of sleep very shortly.
So don't worry.
Run.
Where's the strong stream?
How could it be trash?
You're too nice to me.
Oh, we have super fast speeds.
Wow.
Oh.
Oh, you didn't see that.
That is terrible.
You think I was being new to this game or something?
No, I'm no, I'm just rubbish.
Did you enjoy your steak dinner?
No, I didn't end up having it because my dad took me to a cafe
and I had like avocado and toast.
I know make it more Aussie kidney if I tried.
And then we ended up no having the steaks because both of us were full.
So we're having chicken instead because we marinated chicken.
Right.
Wait for the platforms to load.
Don't be silly.
Okay.
There we go.
Hold on.
I need to wait for these platforms to load.
Okay.
What did we do?
We didn't do anything.
Oh, there's a we fly there.
How is the world domination going?
Absolutely terrible.
I'm supposed to be the hypnosis and I don't have one hypnosis freaking role play out.
But I promise, I promise I will cook.
Just let me cook.
Okay.
I just need some time.
Bye.
Welcome.
And we.
No.
I thought we were a I thought the map had reset there.
Whoa.
Are you serious?
Oh, okay.
I thought that was bad news, but it's actually not that bad news.
Right.
We just need one more little hermit crab wherever they are.
Is there one under here?
There it is.
I can see it.
I saw it.
I saw a pixel.
It's here.
I see it.
Give me it.
We did it.
Yeah.
See it.
Mission one's already done.
Avocado on toast is an Aussie thing.
So there's been a stereotype.
Well, they say like that's why you folk can't afford a house is because they're eating avocado
toast and it's like rub.
Mummy likes her hypnosis role plays like her steak.
Well done.
Well, I actually have a four part series that's going on Twitter.
I'm need to buy premium Twitter.
Elon's got me and bent over a barrel right now.
Okay.
An E.
Stop fooling around.
I like the bumblebee's voice.
Um,
it's a four part series.
Yeah.
I was just going to.
So originally it was to go on Patreon, but it's against us.
So it's not going on Patreon.
Okay.
We need to rescue a chocoto.
Reeflings forced Johnny to eat a medium steak.
No, no.
Why?
Why not well done?
I didn't want, I didn't want it moving.
And I didn't want the thought of like little worms in it either.
So I said what I said, but if you cook it well done, the worms can't survive.
The we eggs can't survive in it.
If it's a contaminated.
I said what I said, I don't know why well done steak is so controversial.
I love when there's a risk of having worms in my steak.
No.
Said no one ever.
No one wants that.
Okay.
Our objective is just to get to the chocoto.
Chocoto?
Chocoto.
At the end.
Oh my God.
Cream.
Speaking of cream, I cream up.
The no stop.
That's not funny.
How pink does she think medium is?
Well, it's still pink in that.
So that means it's fucking raw.
Okay.
I'm starting to catch on to the game.
That like helps you level up if you look for the balloons.
Only took me how many places to finally get that point across.
Stunning.
I love the poses.
Starting wrong with some pink.
I know that shit bubble gum pink.
Do you remember when that was fucking everywhere?
Oh my God.
I know that's bubble gum pink.
That's like, I know your knobs are different color than your skin.
What the fuck?
Because what would the equivalent for a guy be on that?
Steak doesn't have parasites, that's fish.
Yeah, you want my parasites?
Wait, I can't reach.
Oh, I was gonna say I'm too tall.
Stunning.
That pink is my glove in.
Munkos.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
Hold on.
I'm popping my...
Thank you.
Oh my God.
I loved the little bumblebee's voice.
Sorry.
Is it because I can kinda mimic it?
In my head, I sound like the bumblebee when I do that,
but I bet you I sound nothing like it.
No, but I want to taste your fish regardless.
I don't think there's a mimic...
Well, I thought guys was a...
Oh, I just used my ultima.
And you're like...
Your skin, wink, wink, is like slightly different color?
Like it's darker than what your skin color is?
Am I going crazy or is that not real?
Did I make that up?
I'm like trying to be like...
I'm like...
Okay, no, it's real.
Okay, it's real.
Okay, okay, okay.
No, that's true.
Slightly.
Huh, I never know if...
Yeah, it's darker.
Everyone unanimously getting their tentacle art right now
just to confirm or deny.
We're milling and milling and...
Okay, we're already in two missions.
We're already on Dr. Eggman.
It's darker because it's shrinkable.
Shony, you're the first person I've ever had in 20 players
two years of being an Islamic fantasy.
They like Charmy's voice.
Oh wait, the bee's called Charmy.
Bee, bee, bee, Charmy.
It's so cute.
Oh no, he didn't come down here.
Oops.
Oh, he did.
No, he didn't.
Please don't hit me.
Oopsies.
I thought he was supposed to slow down.
Now, I missed that one up.
Sorry, I went too far ahead.
I'm a silly bee.
A bumblebee for Gen 2 confirmed purely on the basis of the Sonic Hero character?
Yes.
And what are you going to do about it?
Huh?
Are you going to fart?
Are you going to cry?
Oh, I'm getting smoked.
Hold on a minute.
I'm getting smoked here.
Right, here we go.
Hey, here we go.
We camping.
Get him, boys.
Get him.
Do not move.
What are we doing?
No, no, no.
Don't move.
I'm not done yet.
Hold on.
Oh, oh, he's spraying.
Don't be so rude.
Hold on.
I'm not.
I'm too slow.
Yeah, I was going to say I'm too slow.
Oh, he throws a little ninja star.
I never even noticed that.
All right, hold on.
Wait, come stop here so I can beat you up again.
No, I've done it again.
How did I keep doing that?
Draft.
I'm being a silly belly, clearly.
Oh, wait.
I can attack them while he's moving.
Hold on a minute.
We can do damage.
I repeat, we can do damage.
Can I do this and they'll attack him for me?
Oh, what?
I don't know this.
Wait, why am I such a silly belly?
What happens if I use my ultimate?
Can I use it now?
Can I use it right against him?
I'm not.
I'm going burst.
Did that work?
Did I block the game out?
Oh, okay.
Maybe don't use your ultimate against them.
I'm not sure it's going to make the game go funny.
So many things confirmed from Gen2.
It's going to be a big gen.
Bruh, I cannot wait until you guys actually see
what did get accepted.
I have been messing around with you guys
so much being like, this got accepted in Gen2.
This didn't.
This got denied.
But this got accepted.
Oh, I'll take this suggestion.
I'll do this.
I'll further develop that.
I cannot wait for you guys to be strong
and you absolute troll.
I've literally said no to stuff that isn't.
We have here waiting for the trailer.
Transformer in Gen2, you stinker.
Oh, come on.
You have to let me troll.
Let's go.
What's the mission?
Okay.
We're to destroy all the enemies in the safe.
We can do that.
Oh, is there any other?
I can't control the camera at all.
So if there's an enemy behind me and I've missed it,
my bad.
Gonna be honest, chief.
It's my bad.
Here we go.
I don't know how to tell if I've done all the enemies.
So we've got a number at least.
Oh, I don't want bubble.
I want level up.
So we can...
Wait.
Oh, no.
Are they going to go back up?
I need to use espion to get up there.
I think his name is espion.
Are those things going to come back up?
Okay.
They are.
They are very slowly.
They're coming back up.
Pfft.
We know you well enough that you're lying
and we let you get away with it.
It wasn't buggering thin fly transformation
thundershot.
Just doesn't do direct damage at 0 or 1.
They'll find enemies still take damage.
I don't know.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five.
Wah.
I don't like those tanks.
They scare me.
Wait.
Does that count as destroying them?
That does not count.
It's just frozen the guys.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Hold on.
Did the number just go up there?
Am I making that up?
I am pushing against the current as hard as I can.
I think I'm going to have to wait for them to fly back up.
Are they actually down there?
No.
They must have been destroyed.
There's no way.
If we messed up the game,
so this is where I got stuck as a child
and I've not gone any further than this.
Fly.
So it's fly.
Okay.
I'll fly.
I'll trust it.
I'm going to level up the B fully just because.
Oh, there's two enemies here.
I just want to make sure I get them.
I don't want to like move on by accident.
I'm stuck.
Oh God.
I'm so bad at this.
I'm so sorry.
It's because there's a pit.
If it wasn't Haram,
I would bet $100 that Gen 2 includes a slime or a horse girl.
Mm.
Is it because I've made such a deal
about like not liking slime girls?
I wonder if that's why I think that.
Is there anything in here?
No, there's a switch.
What does the switch do?
Oh, it lets me access to the level up.
I'll take it.
Okay.
One, two, three, four.
31 out of 85.
Wait, we've actually still got quite a bit
to go.
Is that a yes?
No, I'm not confirming anything.
I'm just saying that I've been an absolute troll
and I've said yes to stuff that isn't happening
and I've said no to stuff that is happening.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
I should have done that on SP1.
My bad.
Ext interact.
Slime cinch.
Okay, hold on a minute.
I'm not sure how much I can actually
hide my real disdain for some of the suggestions.
We are going to have a carry on next week
and I'm going to draw your gen 2 suggestions
because I'm about to get all the concepts given,
which by...
Oh, they're falling from the sky.
Oh, yeah, from the sky.
Oh.
Okay, don't, no, don't, don't attack.
I guess...
Wait, SP1 just...
He just turned it on his arse?
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
No, go back.
Go back right now.
I saw that.
What am I shooting at?
Wait, how do I get back up?
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Let's...
No!
Ah.
Okay, hold on.
If I hover and then shoot, surely.
Yes.
One more.
M-m-more skills.
Level 3, honing attack.
Homing attack is the tornado.
Wow.
Is there an enemy down here?
No.
I'm just getting trolled, right?
Bumblebee time, sweet little bumblebee.
I know what you want to be.
I'm out of range.
Oh, man.
I'm being super safe with the bumblebee.
I love him.
And it means I can do damage from...
Oh, well, that looks like a hymn.
Oh, I almost missed it.
Oh, no, I didn't.
Right, so can you destroy the tank now?
He can do it on his own.
He doesn't need, like, health.
That's amazing.
All the girls will be muppified.
Toma keys, count your days.
Toma...
If you didn't see it, Toma keys did it to Zura.
I have never interacted with Toma keys,
but count your days, my girl.
I'm coming for you.
You muppify in my...
Do you know how much money I spent on Zura's design
in her model?
And you come along and muppify?
Oh, it's absolutely hilarious.
I love seeing it.
Tea bag in the crap out of it.
Please drop down.
Drop.
Drop down.
There you go.
Muppet strongy win.
Toma, you better not.
A muppet?
Why do I look like a muppet to you?
Two seconds later, it's muppified.
Right.
It's telling me to use him to aim.
Okay.
So, no, that was X.
I was wrong.
What?
Does that don't work?
How does that shoot?
Are you squidding me right now?
I said I'm working.
Tiny.
Sorry, I'm late, strongy.
How's it going so far?
It's going good.
We are playing...
Don't apologize for being late.
I actually started 10 minutes early,
which you're not supposed to do,
but I did it because I'm such a naughty VTuber.
We're playing Team Chaotic.
We're doing ones that I'm not too familiar with.
I've never won on him before on this team.
But I'm trying my best,
and that's the most important thing.
But thank you for the tip, Tiny Spine.
Muppet allure.
Stop it.
Stop saying such thing.
Are you trying to upset me on purpose?
Power is control of the canyon.
Ah!
Did I just hurt?
Oh, I didn't hurt myself there.
I didn't have fun with the later levels in this game mode.
Oh well.
Okay, we're at 73 of 85 enemies.
Okay, okay.
I have no idea if we've missed any.
I have a feeling we probably have.
Team Chaotic hurt me.
Oh no, that picked like the most awkward team.
I have no idea if there's like secret enemies behind me.
I feel like there probably is.
I'll handle it.
Okay, there we go.
Wow.
Right, we'll do this so we can shoot at the guy.
Use the X button.
Do we need to turn back for the railings?
Surely they wouldn't put an enemy on the railings,
like down the other sides.
No, this game is very friendly.
Oh wow, we just killed three.
Wait, we've got four more.
Please tell me there's four at the.
Whoa, I see a little hidden thing to the left.
Did you see that?
Team Sonic is normal mode.
Oh no.
Have I missed two?
We got a complete Peer League before we get map attack.
You're not getting it.
Chaotic is mission mode.
Thank you for the tip, Broly legend.
Oh, thank goodness we did it.
I actually have come.
Oh, right.
Hold on.
Let's just nuke them.
I think we're actually going to do it.
I've never gone past this point
because I got stuck on this one in childhood.
I don't know what I got stuck on though.
That seems really straightforward.
I think Emelur.
Emelur sounds like custom manure.
The P and Peeler stood for puppets this entire time.
It's up to Azura.
The Peeler allegations are complete.
It's not up to me.
It's up to Azura.
I'm just on standby, okay?
I'm on standby.
Now you're not child anymore.
You can fight your inner demons.
Right, there are the Golden Turtle robots.
The turtles control the system.
Sorry, I'm talking over the literal commentary.
We're to find and destroy Golden Turtles.
Okay, Hydration Tech replays.
That's not a Golden Turtle though.
Okay, I don't want a key.
Let's go.
If you do it, I'll do it.
Type of friend.
Pretty much, yeah.
I was so surprised by the girls when we handed over the Twires.
But I'm like, hold on a minute.
You guys are onto something.
Use thundershoot.
What team did you like best?
Rose, because I'm rubbish at games.
And it's a girl team.
And I might be a girl.
And I don't know.
I just kind of...
Oh, why is that locked up?
Why is that locked up?
Oh. Charming.
Oh, someone leveled up.
A crocodile leveled up.
I need another one though.
I need it for the flight.
My charming bumblebee.
I love my charming bumblebee.
Come on.
No, he's like shocking them as they come down.
Estrani's a girl.
I know.
It's absolutely horrifying.
Is there like a secret level up over here, please?
Wait, there actually is.
Oh, no.
I thought there was a level up.
Okay, we've been lied to.
Unconfirmed being a girl allegation.
Shock and behavior.
No, go for the other guy.
No, the other guy.
He's right there.
Oh, they take damage if they fall down.
Why does he keep getting the level up?
Give it to the flight.
Stop giving it to the strength guy.
How do I kill it?
You know what?
I'm gonna just kick and then get my ultimate
and then do this.
Look, it's a little bit cheesy doodling,
but it works.
Okay.
And if it works, who am I to complain?
Thank you.
Am I supposed to do the stripy?
Oh, it's a switched open up.
Oh, right.
Okay.
That makes a lot more sense than I was like, hmm.
Death by bad singing.
Am I supposed to go up?
Is this one of them hidden things?
Oh, it bloody is.
I hate when there's like a path
and you're not sure which one's the right one.
Oh, well, there you go.
Wait.
Is he gonna get me?
Can you aim for the...
Can you...
God, right.
I'm just gonna...
Hello?
Yeah.
No wonder you fell off the map.
What was that?
I mean, what even was that?
I think the game kicks Charmin
all the way in place of like Vespion
when I threw him or whatever his freaking name is.
That was bizarre.
I'm just gonna fly and...
Oh, no, I lost all my charge.
I don't...
Do you want to kick those?
No, I'm scared to like kick,
but he's here.
Right.
I'm literally just camping on top and kicking.
The game hates Vespion.
Oh, come on.
I don't know the names.
Right.
Write the names of my team in Chaotic.
I don't know.
Charming is one.
The game's slippery.
Stoney, you can't hit them from there.
Well, I need to be up at them.
I'm just gonna farm my ultimate.
You see that blue bar at the top, right?
Whoa.
Well, I did something.
Okay, we got it.
Charming could have saved themselves,
but they should have stayed with friends.
Oh.
Okay, we've got two turtle doves and a partridge and a pear tree.
And then what?
I'll just go back down here again.
Oh my god, camera angle.
Please work with me.
It really is...
I don't know why it's not letting me manipulate the camera.
I'll stick to it.
We charming.
Vespion.
Charming in the power guy.
You know what?
You've literally given me nothing to work with.
And you will be punished for your sins against me.
Oh, there's a railing.
I'll collect coins.
Do not read that.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Okay, one, two.
Oh, I lost all my level ups.
Man.
Charly...
Oh, no.
Vector the crocodile.
Espio the chameleon.
And a bumblebee.
Charmybee the bumblebee.
Sweet little bumblebee.
I do like him.
Wow.
Right.
We just need one more golden little turtle enemy.
All right.
I sense gold.
Okay.
And I sense nothing.
Ah, sorry.
I love this flower teleport mechanic.
This is the cutest thing I've ever seen.
I don't care.
I'll take 12 more of them, please.
Okay.
You, Peri.
If I slam down around them, do they become attack balls?
I think they do.
Because he's getting hurt, but I'm not actually doing anything to him.
I can't see the enemy.
Where is it?
Oh, there is.
I found the enemy right in front of my face.
It was on the lower floor?
Oh, don't see that.
Have I just done a circle?
Oh, no.
Is this the start of the map?
Fua!
How was your first YouTube stream?
Hi, Fua and Gain.
Fua, if you didn't know,
Fua, if you didn't know, had her first YouTube stream very recently.
But hi, Raiders.
Amstwarnica...
I...
You do not have a wrench and hammer.
Hold on.
Can I do it?
I know the music just cut out.
Wait, I need to give...
Must give wrench and hammer.
Whoa, whoa, hello.
Hi.
Just for the Raiders, Amstwarnica,
from Violaure.
That's right, the porn company.
Sorry.
All right.
And we're playing Sonic Heroes,
a little childhood game,
but yeah, if you didn't know,
for the Reeflings, actually,
Fua just had her first YouTube,
a little stream,
and she was really nervous for it.
What's that?
I watched it.
Yes, I did.
I know.
I can't believe it.
I haven't...
I have many a time.
Boom, like that.
Just like that, you stand it.
Get wrenched, get wrenched, get wrenched, honestly.
Okay, how's that?
That look good?
I'm just making sure the stream
isn't playing in the background,
and then it doubles up on audio by accident.
There we go.
Okay, we sadly have missed the turtle.
So I think we have to replay
through this entire section again.
Maybe, possibly.
The audio's fine.
I need one golden turtle.
I can't find it.
Okay, I do love the game for that.
I hope your stream has been going well.
It's been amazing, honestly.
I've been spoiled by my reeflings.
So I couldn't have asked for a better streaming time,
honestly.
It's only been a month, but well,
actually, nope.
We're getting close to two months.
Can I do army?
Oh, we're almost halfway through July.
Yeah, almost one and a half months.
Let's fucking go.
Oh, I love streaming.
Oh my god.
I love my life.
Oh god, I'm so out of it right now.
There's one up ahead.
Someone's waiting for me right now.
Whoa!
Not from Veiler.
That was not supposed to happen.
Hi, Broly Legend.
Thank you for the tip.
I said hi, Broly Legend.
What do you use the not the Veiler for Peeler?
Damn, already.
It feels like a debut just happened.
Time goes by so fast.
It's not even possible to keep up.
I hope there's a guy here.
Is he here?
Okay, maybe I'm starting to understand
why this is like such a long game.
I didn't think they were bad.
Man, Fletcher and Gage are really good.
Am I going in circles?
Did I miss it?
Oh, we found them.
We found them.
Literally, all we have to do is nuke them.
Ah, we did it, we did it, we did it.
Let's go.
Next level.
He was back there.
Oh, well, I found another one.
I guess they must put multiple on the maps
in case like you get stuck
because no one wants to be stuck.
Slonic hero stages are notoriously big.
That took me eight minutes to kill three things.
That's how long that took.
That's shocking behavior.
Shawnton.
Okay, stop fooling around.
Yeah, no, maybe I was the voice actor
for Charming, maybe?
A little Charming roleplay.
Look at them pixelated yetis.
I don't know how pixelated it comes across
on your screen, but I can feel the pixels on my end.
Who's this broad?
You mean the bad guys?
Team Darkseid just taking like 16 minutes long.
Oh, god.
I don't know how to fight.
What am I doing?
Oh, my god, stop.
Give me the freaking B level up.
Go.
I'm freaking scared.
I'm scared.
Give me the B.
Okay, we've got the B level up.
That's all we need.
We're level two on the B.
Get off the map.
Off the map.
Off it.
No, they got me.
Get off the map.
Okay, we got rid of the bat apparently.
I'm scared.
Okay, they're just like a pair of stunlocks right now.
I'll take it.
Get off the map.
Get off it.
He's just got nuts down there.
Where is he?
Oh, there he was.
He's there.
I see him.
Go away, Shadow.
Get off the map.
Oh, I'm freaking sick.
I don't know how to do this, honestly.
Okay, hold on.
He's actually annihilating me.
I'm using my ult.
I don't know how to throw him off the map though.
I'm just going to spam with...
We charm in.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, we ulted.
Giving them the silver treatment.
Wait till Shadow uses his special technique.
A gun.
Okay, yeah, I did that.
That's right.
Give me an A.
And why was that a C?
I did it in under two minutes.
A C?
Shouldn't that not be a B then,
if it's supposed to be under a minute?
I want to play!
Yeah, if anyone is like...
Just spam tornadoes to speed character
and you win in less than 10 seconds.
They weren't walking in moe tornadoes.
Thank you for the tip, tiny spiny.
Quite literally with the game.
Right, what was the objective?
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh, get coins.
Look, top left, it says get coins.
I don't know.
Whoa.
The triggers are reversed.
They're on the wrong side.
What?
When I do left and right, it's wrong.
Okay, hold on.
I need swaps of one of the others
because I'm getting nowhere.
Okay, did that help?
Is that where I want to go?
Oh, that level up feels good for me.
I need to get what?
I'm trying to get up, I am.
I'm trying to get up.
Okay, we did it, we did it.
200 rings.
Okay, wait, this is like straight gamble.
Well, if we just need coins,
did I kill that guy back here?
I did.
Oh, no, I picked up the key.
Oh, I really don't want to do any of those missions.
I accidentally got the key.
Oops.
Oopsie, whoopsie.
Yeah, for anyone that wondered why I base off the OSTs,
just listen to the music and appreciate what it's like.
It's just so beautifully crafted.
Maybe not this part,
but it's supposed to show falling into descent.
Whoa, no, come on.
I was doing it.
I can't, it won't let me select the guy that's stuck in the machine.
I could have gambled that, come on.
Casino.
I can't get inside.
What?
Okay, no, go in.
He is bugging out on that thing.
I can hear it from over here.
I'm so sorry for that noise.
The game, he's stuck in here.
I can't even push him out.
Oh, I pushed this out somehow.
I don't know how I did that.
$2, give me more coins.
No, I'm trying to get out of this section.
Yes, there we go.
Okay, let's go in here.
Jeez.
Okay, we did it.
I hate when I can't get inside too.
I was freaking so stuck there.
Try my best.
Uh, we've apparently lost Speedy Gonzales.
We've just straight up lost someone up for the speed character.
Nope, how much do we need?
We need 70 more coins.
We've like straight up lost him.
He's not even respawning.
Now she'll lose the house to Gamba.
Espo dead.
He's literally popped his clogs.
He's had enough.
I mean, I hope we can progress.
What?
I really hope we're not going to get a section
where we need him because hello.
Oh, I did not mean to do that.
I'm going to be the bumblebee in case we get put into a very unique situation in a minute
because why is it not spawning him back in?
With him gone, you will know smell the cold.
He got lost in the Gamba.
That's exactly why I didn't show up.
See kids?
No.
Whoa.
Okay, we did it.
I don't know how, but we did it.
Is this not a jump against the wall one?
Okay, it's this one.
What are we looking at?
Come on.
We must be close by now.
I need to destroy these guys.
Let's just do that.
Espo back.
He paid his Gamba debts back.
Actually, I wanted to ask you about the...
What?
Why did we win?
Because we destroyed enemies?
I mean, I guess you get money.
I had to wait to say five minutes.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I apologize to any Fuwa.
Enjoy.
I'm so sorry.
I'm probably butchering her name as well.
My accent, Fuwa the Neko Vtuber.
Thank you to anyone who's binchening.
She had a fantastic first little YouTube stream.
You got 218 rings from that fight.
Okay, I'll remember that.
If there's another money mission, I'll try and remember that.
That Yakuza game.
Is the Yakuza games good to play on stream?
Like, am I going to be able to play them on stream?
Because I am interested in them.
I'm not going to let...
No, I don't want to play the freaking...
I accidentally picked up the key.
Forgive me.
Oh, see, that's what I don't like.
I randomly yank your momentum.
Oh my god, but it's so Kawaii-ne though.
Hold on a minute.
The music cannot be jamming.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so Kawaii-ne though.
What am I supposed to do?
I don't know.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Don't hurt him now.
Oh, sugar rush.
Wow.
I assume...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, yeah, I'm sorry.
I couldn't do it.
I suck.
No!
Are we done?
Hydration check.
I'm currently hogging the microphone
because I freaking picked up the thing wrong.
Okay.
Oh.
Sorry if you get motion sick.
This probably isn't the scene for you right now.
Oh no, not the bombs.
Oh wait, I'm running out of time at the bottom?
Oh my god, I have to get through this level.
What the heck?
Oh, I'm out of speed boosts.
I'm out of speed boosts.
Oh, we made it.
It's fine.
Plenty of time.
Jeez.
Right.
Do not let me pick up a key again.
I do not like that.
I'm literally hogging the microphone.
I am.
I've got a big man.
Not I'm something.
Team Chaotix blasts give tons of rings.
I wonder, I guess maybe because it's their thing.
Oh, we got two lives out of that.
I mean, sure.
I'm probably going to throw myself off the map somehow.
Bingo highly.
Uh-huh.
This is the song that my theme song is based after.
Notice how it goes ear to ear.
My background music goes ear to ear.
If you listen, nice thing.
Oh, let's try it again.
Hold on.
I think I wasn't supposed to do it that way, but we did it.
Strony's panic when she realizes Sonic games want her to go fast.
Okay.
Oh, dear.
That's not the best outcome for that.
Oh, I love this.
A very important chip.
Oh, I'm so sleep deprived, but this song is so good.
No.
Oh, I need to level everyone up.
Okay.
What does this do?
Well, hold on.
I need to give you your motherfucking wrench.
I show you, Ms.
You're being punished by becoming a moderator.
Yeah, you have been punished.
Congrats.
Do not resist.
Well, it's running.
How the last time we saw Mismar was, um, give me a wrench and I'll get right or
to work on open VTubers to work POV.
Honestly, that's terrible, but it's kind of true.
How are you doing?
Don't miss my last.
I knew you were on Pokemans.
Whoa.
What?
I can't.
It won't let me swap to be.
Okay.
Now go.
Oh, there we go.
Bingo highway.
Not those kind of chips.
Silly.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I guess I didn't want to get that.
What?
That like completely bugged out.
Bingo.
Oh, that wasn't paying attention.
Hold on.
I was supposed to.
All right.
There we go.
Sorry.
I'm supposed to hit.
There's a bit of a strange delay going on.
Is there a chip up here?
I mean, it must be down here.
Hold on.
Let me get my team back since they all despawned.
Uh, I'll just use my own pure laziness.
Now not only the other mods can ban me, but VTubers as well.
Exactly.
The DH Charmy.
In the original game, he's married with kids.
The little bumblebee.
Who's he pollinating?
Married with kids?
Well, I had a divorce in the retcon of the lore.
Like, what?
Oh, I see it.
I want the chip, please.
4 out of 10.
What happens if I pollinate, huh?
What are you going to do?
Nothing's happening.
I won't let me go in.
Go in, please.
Yay!
He was so very...
What's playing Pokemon got very sad
because there was one I really wanted to catch trying to cast.
He stopped that.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I was so lucky.
Hold on.
He's pollinating every queen out there.
He's like that.
Pollinating every sunflower, you can find.
Conquer is bad for a day's style.
Wow.
You're okay.
5 out of 10 for Chiep.
I think.
Ms. Margell has an ASMR stream coming up
if I'm not mistaken.
If I've not been taking a cheeky peek at you,
I think you do.
Enemy's up at home.
Whoa.
Can I get?
Yeah, I need him.
Yeah, I need...
Are we out?
We did not just out of bounds.
No!
Hold on.
Okay.
I think we...
Okay, we can get back in.
I have never done that in my life before.
Okay, let's go.
I didn't...
I haven't...
Oh, whoa.
Hold on.
I think...
I think maybe...
Yeah.
Yeah, I was going to say that's a little bit too sad.
Ultimate time.
Yeah, fun fact about that, ASMR.
When it happens,
I'm banning everyone on YouTube except you!
This is the way...
How dare you?
You wouldn't ban my reeflings, would you, though?
Come on, we're just here.
Oh!
I missed!
Oh, I didn't realize...
How is that supposed to know
I was going to be chilling there?
Seriously.
Oh, my God, I'm going so fast.
Please, I just want this.
Okay.
Okay, do not fall off the mat.
Oh, no!
There was one back there!
How...
How am I supposed to see him?
How many do I need?
I need two more.
And I've passed two.
Oh, but one more!
One more, one more!
Okay, we've got a bingo though, poggers.
There are more than 10 chips.
Okay, thank goodness, because...
I can see the rest of the map there.
I'm glad I will see good map design and stuff.
Like, if you're going to make me aim for like...
I can see a chip up there.
Can I get it?
Oh, no.
I cannot because I've fallen...
There, right.
Oh!
Ta-da!
We did it!
I like how friendly they have been in this game.
They could have made this so difficult if they wanted to.
And yet, they've like put extra stuff then, so...
Thank you, development team, for many a year ago.
You did fantastic.
And I think you should give yourself a pat on the back
because you have made the game not frustrating
by doing these kinds of things.
Thank you.
We're just a couple of little guys.
Stroney, you're such a good gamer that you're breaking the game, honestly.
I'm a little bit...
No clip to game by accident.
Awesome!
Totally awesome!
I fucking love charm...
Charm.
A fight?
I can't remember how many levels there are
or if it's the same for everyone, but...
I think it's like Haunted Mansion.
And then...
An airship?
Wow!
Can I get...
Okay, we've got one level up on Espeon.
Oh, there's...
Give me that!
No, go to him.
Yes.
No, do not spawn in the enemies!
No, go for him!
Okay, there we go.
He's leveled up to two, surely.
Surely.
Stop bouncing on that.
Wait, I saw those air birds though.
14 for Dark, which is the one with all levels.
Okay.
She's gonna become a bee.
Bee, bee, bee.
Charming bees.
I just loved it.
I just think he's cute.
And neat, okay.
Oh wow, wait, we don't have...
I guess we need level three in order to get these guys in one shot.
I'm just sending them to go do it.
Sorry, I'm sorry, okay.
It's the real cannon level, the forest level,
and then Haunted and then airship.
And then we're done already!
We're out.
No, bitch.
Not, bitch.
Stop bouncing on this freaking jump pad.
I can hear it.
You're getting distracted, teammates.
I just...
No, go attack.
Oh, there's one more.
Okay, we got it, we got it.
The silver ones are armored.
Only power and falling does damage them.
I do admit I love the safety of the flying.
I'm sorry, cream carried last time and our tails did.
Oh, that's an ultimate if I've ever seen one.
Oh, they do get tons of money.
I like it, I'm here for it.
I got more money for those kills?
Wait, we already have Team Blast again.
Okay, let's just ultimate since there's a turtle, guys.
Hold on.
You need to replay the bridge mission on Microsoft to balance this game.
So, my dad was, as I said yesterday,
but my dad was legit laughing at me.
I'm like, bro, I'm beating him up.
Okay, that's an ultimate again.
We're on...
Wait, can we just keep repeating the alls if we get coins?
Hello?
Can we just keep going like this?
Those were easy ones.
Okay, I'm learning the strats about Team Chaotic.
I'm here for it.
Money farming.
You can chain them together as Chaotic if you defeat enough.
Wow.
Wow, there were a lot of them.
I'm here.
I'm getting it.
Real Canyon!
Oh, it's our mission objective.
Ooh.
I like when you hold eggs, they all look backwards.
It's so cute.
I wasn't paying attention to the mission,
so we're just going for it.
Let's go.
I assume need for speed.
Get up to 200 miles per hour,
and then the game...
That's the mission done.
Let's go.
I'm not just...
Why am I going so slow?
Am I going crazy?
I feel like I'm going really slow.
I even want to press X.
Am I supposed to tap it rapidly?
I'm tapping.
I needed to be the bumblebee.
Right, I'm being the bumblebee,
but I know what to do.
If you turn into the lane that goes faster...
Ooh.
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, my God, that makes my...
I've not been funny, but that falling makes my clean shot,
because I literally can see the fall distance.
I'm going, I'm going, and...
I am so slow.
I don't think I'm supposed to be doing it this way,
but I'll just send it.
I'm going, I'm going.
Okay, we did it.
Level up bumblebee.
He certainly looks like it to me.
I don't know about you, but...
Do not pick up that key.
Do I make myself clear?
Yes.
Nope, not that. This one.
Taking Strony on a roller coaster ride.
I'm scared of roller coasters.
I don't even know how you guys do it.
People are like, oh, I'm so glad I got to go on the upside down curvy.
Why is the camera locking like this?
Fly, okay. That is why.
The camera said I've had enough of your shenanigans.
No, no, no.
Camera, please work with me.
I'm begging.
Okay, there we go.
We're doing it.
And maybe a really awkward way to do it,
but we're very slowly doing it.
Okay, look.
The rabbit or the hare?
Wait, no, that's not it.
The turtle or the rabbit?
Oh, this sounds so badly.
So badly.
They must.
And this is why we're the fricking
Bumble Beach.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not well enough to be having heart attacks like this.
Come on, let's send me, please.
What's this?
Push me back. Don't do that.
I guess we fly over.
Wait, we can't fly over.
No.
Put me back.
Why even?
Why? Why even?
Why even place such a thing there?
What even is that?
So only the middle one sends you back.
And if you're dumb enough to pick the outer ones,
then that's on you.
Please, camera angle.
I am begging you.
Sweet little bumblebee.
I mean, he did try and save us,
but we didn't do it.
Hard clench.
Rail canyon is such a buggy level.
The only time I die in this game
is legit due to,
like, the camera not being nice
or
the mapping going funny.
Like, it shouldn't do that.
Again?
Okay. I'm not to be the bumblebee,
I don't think, when I'm on these,
but he's the safest.
He's literally the safest thing in the game.
Because you can pick yourself up
when you drop fall off.
Right.
And then the other rails.
Now destroy that.
Right.
Oh, there's something in here.
Oh.
Okay. I thought it was going to, like,
a switch or something.
The rails are so scary.
Okay.
And now I'm too low level to do anything
from a distance again.
No. Bumblebee.
Okay.
And then press the button.
And then I guess, jump aboard.
Are you squid me right now?
Something I think we've learned
is that all we need to do is drive
strongly around at high enough speed
and that instantly makes her woozy enough
to be in subspace.
I'm so confident on her bike,
but not in the car.
Why would you want me to be a nosy
then? That's so mean.
I was so ill because of that taxi.
Thank you tiny spin.
But I was so ill.
Why would you want me to be a nosy?
I had to, it literally was so bad
it didn't go away after, like, a sleep.
Oh, there was a bomb.
I'm sorry. I see it now.
I see my ignorant ways.
I'm just going to play it safe.
Drive her around.
Just pick her up and spin her.
Get the siph.
Is it the siphon-trypical force?
Yes, this looks correct.
Stay on one of the buttons.
I'm being trolled.
I'm actually refusing.
Just carry her. 10 hour car, right?
I wouldn't even make an hour.
I am so terribly
bad.
The siphon-trypical...
I can't even remember the fricking word.
It's like siphon-trypical force.
Oh, and a level up.
Oh, we can finally destroy.
Please do not perish me and begging.
Against my greater judgment
I will go
we espion-vespion
because
I think they've only made it
with these height
hitboxes in mind and that's why
I keep getting perished.
I really don't want to lose.
I run now.
I'm moving, I'm moving.
I promise.
I'm going, I'm going.
The sound effects are actually
bugging out a little bit.
Wee!
Any movie shows
watch along the streams
coming up
not until two weeks
away.
When
Meeda goes home
I am going
to do a ton of back to back
to back to back streams, okay?
To make up for all the missed membership streams
like I'm talking like daily membership streams
I'm like public streaming
to make up
for all the streamies that I miss.
But for the next
two weeks, no, there's no ASMR
and there's no
did I just miss?
Okay, I think I'm supposed
to go this way. Hold on.
Okay, that looks right. Yeah, that looks right.
Now that you mentioned
Siphonchic Focal Force, did you know
that you can use it to scramble eggs
without breaking the shell?
That's cool, I like that.
I like
there is, hold on, what's in here?
Money!
Well, I don't need it, but thank you.
Someone else might need it. I'll take this one though
because it's okay, I won't take this one.
Are you squiddling here or what?
Freakin' in a...
Having your head spin from car rides
gives a wonderful excuse to plan in X-Tress
stops on a road trip to make your head
spin in other ways.
Eh?
Tim Shull, what did you say?
Having your head spin from car rides
gives a wonderful excuse to
plan in X-Tress
stops on a road trip
to make your head spin in other ways.
Is this
refling asking for head?
Yes or no?
Be honest, what did you just ask for?
I'm too, I am
so sorry, I'm so sleep deprived
right now. I am fighting
for my life trying to speak English to you.
I
am fighting for my life.
Okay, let's go
him again.
I was supposed to go up?
Why
jump?
Don't make me jump.
Wait, did I just do a circle?
I think I may have just done a
circle?
No.
Oh, actually I've
miraculously appeared where I need to be
at the right moment.
And now go for it!
Wait, there's something
in the middle there.
Shawnee doesn't even speak English
honestly.
Oh shit, hold on.
Stop, camera please.
Wait, that wasn't even a
This is just for monies?
Oh no, it's not.
Wait, I've done it, no.
Okay.
Assume
this?
Okay, it worked.
It worked.
We're doing it, we're progressing.
Hi.
Thanks for joining me.
I don't know when I think Shibi is.
What?
Was I supposed to do
something there?
Shibi and Azura are collabing here, it's
Audra.
I don't think I'll be able to redirect, I don't
know. Maybe.
What is happening?
This is making my head
stand.
I'm trying, I promise, I'm trying my
best.
Oh, we did it!
I didn't expect that.
Another endurance stream.
I don't even know if I'm going to last two
hours, I'm going to be honest.
I'm not kidding when I said I haven't
slept.
So I did Isaac with you
and then
I went out with my dad
and I did all this stuff and we
found my mom,
found my granddad.
I got a two hour nap
after the cafe.
I woke up
and I was like, I don't need to stay because I'm
full.
And then I've been up freaking
working doing all this behind the scenes stuff
and I still didn't
raise Shibi's script, which I need to write.
It's just
a simple ear cleaning script
that I forgot.
I'm to
okay, I'm to destroy these
little egg capsule design
things.
If you don't feel well, take a break. No, no, no,
I know, I know.
I think maybe we could probably
do a Sonic Heroes marathon
though. I wouldn't mind trying
100% this game.
In terms of doing all the
gang stuff.
I don't know about collecting all
the emeralds, that's something
even I'm not sure I've got
what does this do?
Nope, nope.
Have you considered
a sector or other sports stuff?
It's just
I don't know
how I had the brain power to even do anything
about that.
It's just things need to calm down.
That's it, there's so much going on
but things aren't calming down just
quite yet. That's what I'm waiting on.
But essentially
I'm about to have no
major
role
at all. I'll just be full
strummer.
Please actually
perish this so he doesn't get caught.
Okay, there we go.
Oh gosh,
I don't know if I'm going to get all these.
I hope to police tons around the map.
But yeah, sorry
I'm really not able to articulate
quite well at the moment.
Do you apologise?
Turns out if you didn't get enough sleep
it affects your ability to communicate.
Weflin love, thank you.
I think
I might call it at the two of remark.
I'm trying my hardest
to even speak. I is so
hard right now.
But thank you for understanding. Thank you for the tip as well.
She
No, she
apparently doesn't know that
she's not supposed to stream every single day.
No, I think I like
it. I like the consistency. I like
the idea of you being like
you know, like oh
you know
I fucking come on
a sentence
please. Oh the consistency is nice
because like oh
it's this time, Strong's was going to be on.
I like that. I like the familiarity
being like oh you know what
I'm bored or I want to listen to something
in the background while I work.
Strong's was online, right? I'll have a
we listen in type thing. I like that.
There's like 6
or 80 on the map. Oh thank goodness.
If there's that many on the map
I'm not stressed. Right. We'll level up.
That's what I want to see.
Sleep fun. No, no.
Don't give me my money.
I'll go off it too. How about that?
Thank you Doomsday Dan
for the tip. I'll
go off it too. How about that?
2 hour mark. I feel like 2 hours is fair.
And then
we'll do a Sonic Heroes
Marathon
and we'll finish it.
Don't think I didn't spot this one.
I might be delirious
but I spotted that a mile off.
It's nice
being here with you every day. Well it's nice having
you every day. I'm very lucky
that
you know even
you know even though I'm a bit
special I'm a bit different. You know what I'm saying?
Can I go in please?
Okay there we go.
Strong's standard time
honestly.
That's nice.
I don't feel
pressure streaming.
Oh I need to do this.
Oh I messed up.
I don't know. It's just such
chill and pleasant
time.
I do speak on it often but I don't
feel
streaming daily is taking too much
out of me. What it is
is that
things haven't calmed down
because
a new thing pops up and I'm like
oh crap that's right.
I
said it a wee bit but
the girls got a little
sidetracked
and the audios weren't really recorded
in time for the editors to pick it up
so then I had to kind of pick up a bit of it.
Oh I see it.
I see it.
I was up editing
my stuff and I've got zero stuff to do
and
the girls have over Emi, Mersi, Shibi
and Asi should all have at least one audio
up for this month but it's kind of
those things where like I kind of really
planned for it. The girls were having fun.
Of course they got distracted. They're only human.
I'm not going to be a weirdo and be mad at them
or whatever like the fuck.
Oh!
Can I destroy it?
No I can. Okay just be nice
and careful.
And then it's like yeah I had
this stream plan come on
and why am I flying?
This is a fan!
Oh my god wait
the games
registering me is falling
no.
Yeah this is the only place
where I see it. I was here for a month
I was actually here for a month.
Feels good man. Sorry I just fell off the map there
and just about did it again.
Game?
Game doesn't like me.
I keep it.
I've never had so much issues playing Sonic Heroes
but Chaotic I think that's what
three instances now where it's been about
hmm.
And destroy it. That's 18.
And then we've got 19, 20
and 21 up ahead.
Okay I was
worried I wasn't going to reach that but I did.
21.
Put charming thing thank you to the donation.
Thank you.
I'll just get myself.
Oh what was the audio theme?
I might have been the writer for it.
I'm so sad when
August happens because
August means I didn't write
everything
so I can't get the credit for writing something good.
It was the weird girl one.
There was two weird girl ones
that month for her.
But thank you for the five bully legends.
Was it the one where the neighbour needs
a liquid
or was it
Oh I wasn't paying attention. Jump.
I can't
sue.
Hold on I need to actually
use aimbot because I've only got two lives.
What the heck is that?
I'm holding.
But yeah basically
once August starts
up like the August audio is coming out
I didn't
game.
Hey game you know how you were supposed to
propel me halfway across the map?
Did you forget
that detail or
I
have never perished so much in Sonic Heroes
I'm all the way back here
on the games test
and me.
It's literally test and medicals
I'm all the way back here
Game is asleep
deprived of strong so I don't know
I can
skip these ones.
Oh I'm gonna say it.
The game is not game in.
Todd wouldn't say
it just worked.
We do a little teasing
we do.
I still write all my
own stuff but that's because
I've lost them your honour.
I'm gonna stay on like this
I don't know why the beating would propel me forward.
This is freaking
adorable.
Oh yeah for marriage you need to kiss me right now
Thank you boy
for the tip.
And Brian for announcing
I appreciate Brian in these parts.
Maybe I can get the one that's up ahead
Whoa.
Yay!
Please do not throw me off the map this time
I'm begging
Don't throw me off the map
Boom
What's going on?
Why are you putting me on him?
It keeps putting me on the B
I entered that
as the crocodile and it keeps
putting me on the B
I think because I keep losing
Speedy Gonzalez
Honestly the game could throw me on any other day
I'm like please not this day
I've had no sleep over I think it's
I don't know how long
It must be over 30 hours at this point
I've been awake
Because a two hour nap unfortunately
is not enough to replenish the
the old juices the old brain waves
It took me actually I edited
a bonus
like a subscriber special audio
but
again I don't know if I can upload it
to YouTube right away until the warnings
await purely because
purely because because because
because
the audio
is me sitting on the mic
I'm like repeatedly sitting on the mic over and over
I cannot see
right okay this time he is fully
on me we have all
three of us together if this glitches out
one more time I'm gonna cry because it really
shouldn't
I'm not sure what to do
if it doesn't propel me forward I might
can't be a framerate issue
can he be
it's a speed thing as well
there there there oh we did it oh my god
right we don't even have to do that section
even
every time a glitch happens this one here is the
place of my head
keep going forward because that's what I did back
when I went through this level
just don't breathe
you'll be fine
okay stop
going around oh I love them
I love the beat sweet little poppy
apparently Mary divorced and has kids
I know what you want from me
it's the divorce paper
something like that anyways
egg albatross
oh I've got a little cheeky
headache coming on right on the right side
of my skull
can I
injure these guys from here
wait but they're not
taking damage like that
that's what we don't want
whoa how am I supposed to
get past the thunderstruck
oh
oh there's level up on this side
yeah give me level up please
or not because
he just refuses to knock them down
are you squidding me right now
oh wait wait did I fall for a prank did I get pranked
did I get tiny spiny
did I get pranked
I would like to keep my coins please
so I can do an ultimate blast next to him
I don't know maybe I'm better just than this
to get my ultimate blast unlocked
yep I just don't exist
yeah yeah yeah do that
oh come on let me use my ultimate
next to the airship
come on just come a little closer
you know you want to
you know you want to come so close to me
you want to come so close it hurts
okay okay come closer come to me
you're like here
yes and then ultimate
castle I know would ever do that
this is the boss where you homing attack to win
is that actually
oh they didn't get those guys over here
okay we gotta level up but he's not level 2 unfortunately
wait so can he not shoot at me now
now you don't want to you don't want to pick up that back there
nah that's fine I'll just skip over it I guess
so
I won't
I don't know what the deal is
I don't know how to do it
just spam the homing attack this one
well I wait for him to come over to me
I'll let him come back
is it doing damage though
what a homing attack this one
oh it's doing something anyway
okay there we go
what no
I don't do it
I'm very low IQ for this right now
use my ultimate maybe
I keep aiming for this one particular part
oh there it is okay there is a hitbox
can I hit that hitbox
excuse me I would like to hit the hitbox please
okay I can use my ultimate let's do that
oh can I
okay I mean oh shh
we jumping on
oh wow okay I'll take yeah this looks a lot better
because I was getting rather confuzzled
wow
are we done
I almost fell off the map for that
is he actually getting away
I hope not
can I use my ultimate
I can't even reach him
oh I most certainly can reach him I'll take it back
ultimate time
what is epilepsy
that it
espio literally me with
the scrawny airplane
would you still love me if I was an airplane
I said I've just leaked
my alternative
outfit design it's actually a blackbird
SR 71 that I just said its name twice
it's either an SR 71 or it's a blackbird
your choice that was terrible
target destroyed
okay that was an absolute terrible fight airplane
girl gen 2 is real
oh my god I'm thinking
oh we got the jungle man
I would rage every day if you're an airplane
I had the same weird
Dr. Eggman
he wouldn't do something like that
right
oh no the SR 71
how can you get any more powerful
well I honestly wouldn't mind entertaining
an SR 71 gen girl
I don't know maybe someone wants out of it
if no one wants the alternative outfit I'll take it
are we doing this or am I redirecting it to someone
am I
will I like read marshmallows for like a couple of minutes
and then go pass out
did you even read my crystal ball
you have to be invisible espion
what during this map
like this
I mean if it's easy peasy
he's not even here
I'm starving
can't get it
I suck
I
can't even
I can hardly reach
it's a stealth mission you can't be seen by the frog
oh wait this entire thing's a stealth
I had no idea
that's actually such a cool concept
I didn't even know they did that
it says fly
it says fly ahead
I almost got baited
I almost got baited so bad seeing that life up
that's so this is so interesting
oh hold on nope you can get me bitch
look at that massive shuriken I can throw
wow this is cool
just don't get too close to the other frogs
or it's ogre
I like this
there's so much croaking
okay just throw me off the map it's fine I didn't want to play
smile
I could fart on this game sometimes I'm gonna be honest
sometimes this game
I've definitely have to admit
I've never had more issues with like falling off the map
on any team than this one
and I've played like rows over and over and over and over again
but this is like rough
you have to fly over that one
fly over it
we going chaotic difficulty now
I'm flying I'm flying
are you joking
this game has some bangers
woohoo
that's what I get for having nothing but the audacity
to play this
actually I really enjoy this game so it's not shit
okay let's go
let's do this one now
because I've not done this one
I've died so many times I couldn't have done all the path
she didn't
fly so good
that shouldn't be an SR71 after all
okay
let's jump over this frog
okay that was way better
way better
we have a poll in teleport
that's not poll in teleport
that's a poll in ledge
hey there's a frog over there
I love this game but the jank is so bad
oh
I remember you making me like SR71 and transforming me
we should watch the you guys are asking if I wanted to
oh I missed
oh it's okay
you would say that would be
you adorable little thing you
am I to fight
feels like I'm not to fight anything honestly I'm here for
I'm like we're a proper stealth
oh no
I want to be invisible on the flower
woo
how are you supposed to react to these bowls
you come at me so fast
don't murder char- wait you don't like char me
does no one like char me
I think he's
so towards my goats of dwarves
what was that
I'm on a hole
whoa
oh
oh we did it
I didn't expect to do that
stealth mission complete
I've never played that one it was really interesting
I didn't even notice that I like him
he's so annoying
even though hardcore sonic fans
tend to find him annoying
I find him rather adorable
oh yeah
he's just a silly kid
I like his wee goggles and stuff
like cute as well
his wee avi or goggles
did you know in terms of
flight bumblebees shouldn't or something
I can't remember
maybe we could have done a little better
aw yeah
I would punch him if I could
play some little freaking adorable thing
I don't know what I would say the worst
oh god no more missions
uh-huh
10 chow
whoa
oh no
had to destroy these guys
just go for it
drat
not good
can you stun him
yes thank you please stun him can you do anything
what does
I'm out of coins I think
oh that worked
I don't know how but it worked
lost the one up there clearly
one day I should remember what movie she wanted to watch
I'm so tempted to
redirect into someone and go to bed
I'm so sorry
unless I love streaming I'm absolutely
out of it right now like I can
do the Chacoa I've already got three
I knew it I knew it was going to be up there
I knew it the game was screaming
the server was up there
right let's get the last one
and we'll wrap up okay
whoa
I forgot his height is different
it's funny to see how
team Sonic is normal and Shadow's hard
but K.O.T. is just totally different
you don't have to read them just go to sleep
okay I finished this one
and then we take a break
and we all get a good night's sleep
and I'm going to dream about
about you hugging me
and putting me to sleep because I'm fucking dying
not to be dramatic or anything
but I'm hanging by a thread
smile
okay let's get our Chacoa
no no fall
okay
let's just
I'm going I'm going let me finish
really legend things
I'm going I will literally
go to bed after this one I'm not even
I will not fight and I promise you with how
I feel right now I am not fighting you
is there something here
wow
okay we've got five
and we've only just started this level
so we're doing fine
I've been
I missed it sorry
sorry the flying
characters are actually just so op in this game
okay they're hiding them at the side of the screen
so every time the camera
is forced forward I will go to the
side of the screen because you're getting too obvious
right
rain rain rain I see the level
up on the right side look it's
Nisturshem
do you see the lily pad leaf and then the
flower these are modeled after Nisturshem
Nisturshems are everywhere
if you look for them they're an absolute beautiful
flower
they are very
hardy plants and terms
oh mommy get sleep maybe
visit by one for dream
I'm gonna have all the dreams because
I
been looking and loving and thinking
and dreaming
uh
chow
I
see the chakua
come here
oh there we go I needed a platform
yes I will feel very much better
and like
all I need is one big sleep
and then I'll be back to myself again
I'm talking
about all the sleep is making me even
sleepier that's right I said it
on the purple
mushrooms put my eyeballs to sleep
uh did I just
I'm gonna spam this until we unlock
the uh
ultimate because I am not fighting these guys are you
kidding me you need more than
two hours of deep I know I know
I was nori I was doing the editing
the work
but yes for bleeding hearts
I promise there's audio
is coming out next that's the next thing
I'm working on and I'm doing she be
squipped
charming
we should all sleep together
hey gents it's just come out yeah
we did it
clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap if
you want to clap
I can hardly get anything
that took four minutes
what's the score
cuddle puddle
I like the sound of that cuddle puddle
that's not such a good way to do it yeah man go greatest
of all time
we're done I watched the kiosk
concert
date
that's me
it's not nice to tease my friends
be nice to my gen mates guys
alright
someone said do A and X
I'm just spamming A and X
what
what's this music
it's got words
I'm not being dumb
have I never heard this before
or paid attention
I
don't do that lol
what
I hope not copyright
I can probably edit it out because the stream is
short enough
get off the map Amy
jeez
team rose more like team never getting off the
fucking map
get off the
map
I got altered
can I swap to my
freaking flight guy please
they ultimated on
my ass cheeks
and respawned their freaking teammates
no soz I'm just staying here
I'm actually staying up here
and I'm farming my ult
cause
what was that
what was that I didn't know they could
use their ultimates
that's so weird hearing singing
she sounds like a horse though
I've never seen the speed character
stay on so long
get altered
no no no do not lose flight
what is that AI doing
okay where is she
get off the map right now
yeah you're gonna have to go for someone else
cause it ain't me
off jeez la ways
that took forever
cream the horse
last time I fought him he just jumped off the ledge manually
that was awful
what can that be all
I honestly can't even survive
oh we're in haunted mansion
the jank has me dying
I don't know how I could be so unlucky in one run
I used up all my luck in Isaac
obviously
cause I've been flying off the map
willy nilly
oh I do love the music in this game
my eyes are glazing over right now
I actually can't even focus just to see
right
I assume if I do quit it saves my last progress
fair trade honestly
oh wow we're 73% of the way there
did I just go
I don't think I can send it
I tell you what we'll do a marathon and we'll actually do 100% on everyone
deal
deal we'll do 100% on everyone
okay
slumber time
right I'll see if there's anyone I can be direct into
and
I think
Sheeby and
Mercy's club
it says Mercy's coming up first
wait it says only Mercy's coming up for me
hold on a minute
Mercy modi so I don't know if I'm yourself
how far away is she
is she like 1am
1pm off she is
right
I actually can't redirect into anyone
without
oopsies
that's been strong just to kill yourself
for a speech oh okay
right I can't redirect into anyone
apologies but it is what it is
thank you
so so much for hanging Emmys live in 2 hours
okay what I'll do
is I will redirect into Emmys
thing
I'll throw people you don't have to actually sit
for you know 2 hours
um
subscribe
I'm back from
holiday that's all
I will redirect
into this
no you don't have to sit in silence for 2 hours
with it in the background I promise you you can
click off and you can look at something else
okay
but thank you so much for being so understanding
about the situation
um yeah I don't think my dad
realised how much he's kind of pushed me
because obviously I stream
and then I work but I am now
streaming working socialising
and you know
talking to my family and all that and it gets
quite a lot like it
definitely like increases
the stress
Emmys has an offline chat well I've shoved
you into her I'm back
chat so get right
what are you gonna do about it huh are you gonna fart
right thank you so so much for understanding
refunds I'm so sorry that I
sounded so low energy it's because I was
I'm gonna be honest I'm shattered
I'm a puddle I'm a mess
I do have good news about
pheromone maxing however
the pheromones
have not been
maxed at all I've been shivering every
day like an actual normal person it's terrible
absolute shocker behaviour
cut back a little in the part you can make it up later
yes I will make it up later I promise
2 weeks time I will completely make it up
everything that has been
missed out on endurance all that jazz I can go
straight back to it but
it's very exhausting
socialising
I don't know I find it a lot easier to
not socialise smile
I guess okay please take care of pheromones
no still
haven't re-subscribed yet because of that because of the
pheromone maxing have a good nap
strong as well not the pheromones I know
I'm so sorry refunds
but thank you for understanding I might give you
a big smooch on your lips
um
I'm sucking the
soul out of you with this one
just don't talk to people
just don't talk to my dad
okay I'll just stop talking
I won't even explain I'll be like
sorry
I'll be like I'll be like uh uh uh
and I'll have my hand and then do the little chin point
and I'll mug him
which is thank you so so much I'll see you
QB2E's tomorrow
I have no idea what I'm streaming tomorrow
I can very quickly look
I'm looking I'm looking
tomorrow
we're playing honeycam studios
oh my god
that had a death grip on everyone
I'm very curious to see how that stream
is gonna go I have no idea
the thumbnail
if you zoom in on the thumbnail
okay
I edited it quite a bit
cuddle puddle time let's go
everyone into bed
we will cuddle puddle in bed right now
don't think I won
no more stalling I'm gonna go because I feel very sick
unfortunately thank you so so much
for being chilling
please have a warm welcome
back for M.E.Bzoo in T-minus 2 hours
and then Merci Modiste
and T...she didn't go anywhere
so you didn't need to welcome Merci back
but in 7 hours Merci is live
thank you so much
I will see you soon
tomorrow and we will play honeycam studios
unbelievable
it's this game about us question mark
smile but I'll see you good for good for tomorrow
please look after yourself please hydrate please
have a
I don't know a tinkle yeah have a tinkle
and a snack and a pastry item
maybe a cheeky griggs you know
okay good night I'm actually going for once
I can't believe it
see you tomorrow everything okay bye bye
so sorry bye bye bye I have to go
wow